- You know, like, I don't know
if any of you ended up like ever
hooking up or marrying
your best friend but not that,
I'm (group laughter).
Oh, no, no, no.
We've actually hooked up,
we're just not best friends.
(group laughter)
- [Ryan] Cut that.
- [Gary] That's how
the episode's gonna start.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba mother fuckers.
I've been telling you.
That's a great question.
First of all, and I
think you'll love this,
within my organization and
what I assume here but like the
younger company we haven't had
this talk winning first of all
is very individual.
Like the most interesting thing
for me is actually understanding
what everybody in this room
thinks winning is for themselves
so that we can
reverse engineer it.
That's what I
spend all my time on.
I don't give a shit if you want
to buy the Jets or if you want
to make $137,000 a year have
ridiculously good work-life
balance, still keep a job
when you start your family.
I don't, it's unbelievable how
much I care and how much I don't
care about what
winning means to you.
Meaning I massively care and
then you get to define it.
For me, it's just about the
journey of building businesses.
It is my drug.
It is my oxygen.
I love it.
I love that.
I love this journey because I
want to see how we stack up with
me involved against the
other people that are trying to
capture the attention and so in
essence what it is is one big
game of how do
I provide the most value.
So in return, I get
the attention that I seek.
I'd like to get together just,
I feel like there needs to be
dramatically more communication
from the top with
this small group.
And so, I think for all of you
individually it's a good thought
to think about when
this is on your schedule,
over the weekend of like maybe
the one or two things you want
to bring up of like closing
'cause I never to be strong at
like having the core agenda.
Maybe the Office of the CEO can
take that over for me over time
but I think,
you know, for me it's just
good to get us aligned.
A lot of what I look
back at last six months,
a lot of times things are
happening in pockets of two or
four or six or eight and I think
this will give us an opportunity
to do that and an opportunity
talk about things
that are important.
So that's what I'd
like to do more often.
I mean that to me
that's the big thing.
Whether it's (censored), or
(censored) I want to make sure
we're over delivering on the
quality for it and like start
really having conversations
of what can studio do,
what like how do we
replicate you know like lighter.
The entire market
is recognizing it.
Let's understand what's
actually happening here.
Like at the macro, all of a
sudden after we do these two
things like people believe.
Like only actions
make you believe. Like, right?
The reason I've been pretty
passive is like I'm not willing
to look at rhetoric.
I want to look at actions and
then when actions happen you
have to make
your decisions, right?
We are really,
really, really dangerous and
very excitingly close.
Kieran, sup man?
Good to see you.
- [Kaylen] I think the biggest
manual labor is figuring out how
we're getting global because
global's creating all of the
content right now and
we're adapting that.
- [Gary] Yeah.
We'll figure out that.
- [Kaylen] Yeah.
- [Gary] That
will play itself out.
- [Kaylen] So I think that's it.
There's actually a lot
of momentum on (censored).
- We're gonna throw a
lot of into your guys' pod.
- [Kaylen] Yeah.
- I want to really stretch you
and Lisa because I just want to
bet on both of you and
I want to kind of help you.
I want to speed your process
to the next level so this is if
(censored) goes away,
you may get six new things.
- [Kaylen] Yeah.
- That's (censored)'s
about. You'll see more of that.
And (censored), you'll
just continue to see things.
- [Kaylen] Totally.
- Got it?
Just keep that on the macro.
- [Kaylen] Yes, and I you told
me to eat shit three years ago
and I thought--
- Eat shit.
I'm telling you it's the.
But look, look how
well my eat shit strategy's
worked for your fucking career.
- [Kaylen] Yes, agreed.
Totally agree. Yes.
I'm Kaylen, I am a VP group
account director on a few of our
large CPG brands here at Vayner.
I've been here
for almost five years.
I think the biggest piece of
advice I got from Gary was a few
months being at Vayner, I was
kind of used to PR where you
were constantly on a
lot of different brands and
a lot of different campaigns.
At the time I was really only
on one brand for six months
straight and I had kind of gone
to him expressing the desire to
be on multiple things
and he basically told me to
eat shit for three years.
(laughs) And I think that
there's value in doing one thing
consistently on getting better
at that one thing over time.
And I think he's right.
And so we were just
kind of joking about
how it's been three years.
("Intro" by Jay Two)
- [Gary] Hey Ethan,
it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
How are you?
DRock wants some updates on
DailyVee now so here it is.
I'm working DRock,
that's your update.
I did a meeting
with my leadership team.
I did a meeting with Resy, the
restaurant app that all of you
should be using.
I did a meeting
with a couple individuals
that run key accounts.
Stopped in and said
hello to a candidate.
That's what I did for
the last couple hours.
So when I think about
DailyVee, I always wonder like,
you know it's funny, DRock.
Remember when we started this
like the fourth or sixth or
ninth day episode you were like,
and this was when we were gonna
do it two or three
times a week, you're like,
"How are we gonna come
up with different stuff?"
And so, it's clearly worked out
but I'd be remiss to not tell
you these are my favorite days.
Just a good old
fashioned I'm in New York.
I'm the CEO of this company.
I talk to guys a lot about like
GaryVee being my side hustle.
We are debating very
aggressively on a daily basis
how do we show you more things.
We're trying to do that but
even today like already hard.
Just had a major client meeting.
Was very inappropriate.
Meeting a new very senior client
and I'm empathetic that me
rolling in not only with my
camera guy but we're doing some
still shots today
as well like that's the
douchiest shit of all time.
That could go over very poorly
and so we need to
be empathetic for it.
I love when we're like seeing
athletes or rappers or we're
gonna be in some cool settings.
I'm sure.
I still think you
should come to Super Bowl.
So when can you leave now?
I already told you no
but you can come Friday.
- [DRock] I can come Friday
and Saturday if you want me.
- Well that's the only
time I'm gonna be there.
You'll just leave
Saturday afternoon?
- [DRock] I'll have to--
- Yeah. Done, lock it in.
It doesn't fuck you up?
- [DRock] I mean, it'll be fine.
I'll see my mom
and dad on Sunday.
- You can leave early on
Saturday and I'll do the rest.
- [DRock] Cool.
- Cool.
- [DRock] Let's do that.
- See, this is how we roll.
Anyway, where did I go?
Oh. There'll be cool things like
Super Bowl and like famous
people and they'll be a lot more
as "Planet of the Apps" comes
out and I actually become
more mainstream notoriety,
recognized and
more things will happen.
We have an amazing dinner with
like a very all-time
classic rapper.
So everybody's super mad that
I'm only focusing
on the new stuff.
Old stuff's coming.
But nothing trumps, nothing
gets me going more than a solid
Monday with a shit load of
business meetings where
I'm executing and
delivering on being the CEO of,
you know, a
nine-figure business.
This isn't fucking
kindergarten anymore.
So just thought I'd
tell you I like executing.
I like doing the work.
I like eating my own dog food.
When I tell you
guys to do something,
it's only after
I did it already.
That's the problem
that pisses me off so much.
Some kid literally
emailed me and said,
"Gary, need your help.
"I want to learn
more about social media."
Did you see this?
- [DRock] I did.
- This was insane.
"I need your help and advice
on how to be doing social,
"how to do social media because
I started a social agency."
(group laughter)
So I literally replied to him.
What did I reply?
Like, "Are you charging people?"
- [DRock] Yeah, are
you charging people?
- And I go, "Are
you charging people?"
And he goes, "Yes."
I'm just like
laughing, I'm like,
that's like me charging for
skiing lessons and hitting up
somebody and asking them
to learn how to ski 'cause
I can't ski.
Fucking bullshit.
- [Claude] Hey dudes.
- [Woman] Oh, hi.
- [Claude] What's happening?
- [Gary] All good stuff.
- [Claude] Madelena's
on the phone.
- [Gary] 'Sup, Mads?
- [Woman] It's Gary.
- I'm Gary Vaynerchuk,
CEO of VaynerMedia.
- We're just talking
about performance reviews.
I just went through a
little demo here with--
- How'd it go?
- Really good, really good.
- [Woman] We're gonna bring so
much process and structure.
You're gonna love it.
- [Gary] I don't mind.
("Delusion" by Jay Two)
- What I wrote down
today you're like fix the well,
don't fix the faucet.
- Fix the well, not the sink.
Every time. It's great.
That's it.
- That's just so important.
- [Gary] That's it.
Let me give you
the manifesto on that.
A lot of this is I'm gonna be
the bottleneck so what I would
say is Office of the CEO
should really probably write up,
be very close to the write up
of all these other things 'cause
they're the closest to probably
knowing where I sit on this.
Steve's got creative down.
And Jason and
Aaron I think have video.
I can feel comfortable there.
But on these other things but
let me give you an
example of solutions.
I want to lead the
dog to the well. Right?
Like, I want to basically say,
"We are often asked to help with
"digital work where the budget
doesn't match the need of the
"amount of
creative output for that.
"We have found over the last
five years one of the great
"services we can provide for our
clients is creating a digital
"architecture and framework to
how to be successful in the
"modern mobile world."
I'm gonna review right now my
intuition on the 90% wholesale,
what we do best, what
your company needs most,
let me give you let us present
to you maybe tomorrow, right?
- [Man] Yep.
- Maybe two days but
no more than two days.
- [Man] Wednesday, yeah.
- Wednesday latest,
how we do influencer,
why we've been winning with
Budweiser and Panasonic and
others and how we
would attack this.
Because Facebook commercials are
more expensive and complicated
'cause you get into creative,
paid media amplification,
why don't we go where there is
less politics right now and let
us come with an
influencer campaign for you.
- [Alex] Marques, Gary.
- [Marques] 'Sup?
- How are you?
- Good, how are you?
- Real pleasure.
- Yeah, good to meet you.
- Glad we got to connect.
- [Marques] Yeah,
this is a neat view.
- This is not too shabby.
- [Marques] Yeah.
- Moving on up.
Yeah, tell me what's
going on in your world, man.
And how you're
thinking about it.
- The main thing is,
yeah, no it's a lot of fun.
So I graduated a year ago.
So been full-time
making videos for a year.
Was doing it
alongside school for
all the previous
six, seven years.
- [DRock] Yeah, I used
to watch you all the time.
- Yeah, so it's been like an
evolution of making videos about
tech, consumer electronics,
reviews, explanations.
All that type of thing.
- [Gary] Which is, by the way,
so weird for me because that's
the world I walked into.
When I started Wine Library TV
in 2006 the only
videos online were that.
iJustine, Diggnation,--
- [Marques] Yeah.
- like you know like
Tekzilla, Leo Laporte.
- [Marques] And
that's where I,--
- That's where you
were influenced by, yeah.
Put your energy and forces
behind pushing them to YouTube
if that's where you
decide the right place is.
You have zero
downside of the distribution.
The entire universe is living
on Facebook as well and there's
just no downside.
So here's what I would say.
You know, it's easy when
you eat your own dog food.
I care less about hitting the
vanity metric of how many views
on YouTube I have.
I care about the net impact
of the brand I'm creating.
- [Marques] Yeah.
- So to me if you asked me
what's better 1 million YouTube
videos and zero Facebook or
847,000 YouTube videos and
347,000 Facebook,
you're gonna win that game.
- [Marques] Yeah.
- Not to mention when you start
thinking about real economics
like where you're
really getting into real money.
So like, one of
things that people,
one of the reasons a lot of
people come here is if you
really look at like people to
come and visit me and I hang
with so many of them have way
more followers than me but the
economics I'm able to create are
far greater 'cause that's how
I think about stuff.
When you think about who's gonna
consume randomly your
Facebook videos, they're
the people that are gonna
write the bigger checks.
They're gonna be the people
that are gonna come out and say
here's a $3 million
sponsorship deal.
That just matters and
in the YouTube environment,
you've got to go to it.
In a Facebook
environment, it comes to you.
What I can tell you for sure is
you don't have to pick either or
99% of the time.
There's so much fragmentation
of attention you can't use the
overexposure the
way that people think.
Good creators are romantic
and are calculated
around their art.
- [Marques] Yeah.
For sure.
- And I do think
that you can do both.
Damn, you're a
good looking dude, too.
- I appreciate that.
- Yeah, good to meet you.
- Hit me up anytime.
Hey everybody,
it's Gary Vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 240
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
If you don't have people to give
the influencers and you want
them to come on so
they bring their audience,
you've lost.
- [Tarek] Mhmmm.
- You've lost.
- Unless you're giving
them meaningful equity in
your company, you've lost.
Everybody, it's a
chicken and egg game, Tarek.
You know, everybody wants, you
want influencers 'cause you want
them to bring the million people
that pay attention to them over
and sign up for your world.
No matter how much economics you
give them you're getting more
than you're giving them in that
first move which means you'll
never get started.
You have to solve for that.
You don't actually do it all but
when you aspire to do it all,
you just get to a lot more
of it than if you don't. Right?
Like if I decide I'm
gonna run, right now,
out of this car to California.
Like that is the goal
and mission of my life.
I just have a funny feeling
that I'm gonna run further and
somebody saying I'm
gonna run down the block.
This is war.
So I think people are too
perfect and too refined and are
scared to lose because, and
this is why I started with it,
they care about what
other people think.
I don't care if VaynerMedia
went out of business
what you would say.
Ah, see I knew it.
You suck.
No, I'm gonna rise
like a phoenix and
stick it in your mouth.
It's an important insight and
I'm glad you're responding to it
the way you are
because it's a big deal.
Like I like losing
because I'm not
willing to factor you in to
the equation and for me
losing's going to teach me
what not to do again.
Hey.
- [Woman 2] Getting upgraded.
- [Gary] Hi.
- [Woman 3] Hi.
- [Gary] How are you?
Good to see ya.
(crosstalk)
If we were to do this,
and we were to do it well,
we'd be the number
one brand in one year.
It's that big.
Like we'll invent.
That's what I've
always been good at.
What I've always been good at is
never taking the last medium and
putting it into the new medium.
Right, that's where people lose.
Like if you look at
the first 100 commercials,
they were all radio ads.
("Delusion" by Jay Two)
So obvious that I think,
it's been so heartwarming to
think how many people here feel
comfortable with
what's happening now.
I mean really to be very honest
with you given that I think of
spieled here
before, theoretically,
I'd love to do as much Q&amp;A
as possible right
now to like really.
I'll give you couple top line
thoughts and then I'd love to
answer any questions of your
wondering about like how I think
about things or from my lens,
I'm sure Ryan's given
you a lot of his stuff.
I think that the media
landscape is gonna go
through a substantial change.
More so than it already has over
the last decade and I'm sure for
a lot of you if you work here
you understand what that means
in the scheme of things.
I couldn't imagine progressing
my career with not getting into
the pure media side of things.
But I think I can have a bigger
impact than the companies
I invest in or things of that
nature and so I'm excited to get
to meet a lot of you and
interact and take this journey
together and I, you know,
to me when you sell a
company that shit is scary.
What, you know what's been most
interesting to me
as this got close?
After we had such a fun, like we
had like that was such
a great meeting for me.
I don't know.
I don't know how it was for you
but (group laughter) for me it
was so warm and so
aligned and great questions.
It was so good.
I remember thinking fuck, if
this happens they're gonna feel
safe and pumped.
And so that excited me
and I want to deliver on that
intuitive feeling
that I think a lot of you,
there was a lot of words that
could've come out of Ryan's
mouth of like, "Hey, we sold
to," that I'm sure for many of
you you've been debating
in your mind if it happens,
and I know for fact that the
majority of things that ran
through your mind of where this
company could be sold to were
far less interesting than
what we're about to be up to.
And so that excites me.
So, that's my spiel.
- [Ryan] Awesome.
- Cool. Thanks for having me.
See you soon.
(audience applause) What?
Who's doing what but like but
what I do know is if you own
that and you editorially
executed it well that
the upside is so great.
When you talk about the way
that I think about things,
it's similar to the
answer that I gave you.
A lot of what's gonna come
out of my mind is if this hits,
it changes everything.
And I'm okay to go 1 for 5
because 1 for 5 is net positive
and I believe the
world goes 0 for 0.
And that's just
kind of my general,
if you want to understand
where I think like a macro,
I think the world
goes 0 for 0 'cause people
stay nice and safe.
Do what they do.
Never push it because
they're scared of going oh,
missing 'cause it's
expensive, it took time,
opportunity costs.
To me, we're now in
a place financially,
infrastructurally that we should
try to do the ambitions that
maybe some of you have
on different things as well.
And the other thing is,
back to the point,
I called (censored) like
you should sponsor this for
(censored) or more
and they're like, okay.
There's also that part.
By the way, everybody's thinking
about the one version of the
thing they want to
do that they don't do,
it's amazing when
people are allowed to do that.
The hustle meter goes through
the roof if you're actually
doing shit you want to do.
Like for some
of you, creatively,
you're probably more than happy
to do exactly what you're doing
and do this thing as long as
you're just allowed to do the
thing and you'll do that plenty
afterwards 'cause you just want
to see it, you're creators.
You want to bring it to life.
You know how curious
you are if it would work?
You know what
I like about (censored),
I'm just curious.
I'm real curious.
I also know it's the kind of
thing that leads up to writing
the number one book in America.
'Cause I know that's where all
the action is and God forbid we
stumble on something.
You think NPR knew
that fucking podcasts were
gonna save their business?
Promise you, they didn't.
But if they didn't try
they would have never known.
("Small Conversations
At Parties" by Derek Pope)
No shit. This is,
ready for this?
This is a macro version of
what I just told
your editorial staff.
Because we're in
the yes business,
we didn't know what the fuck.
We just kept getting to a place
where we're like wait a minute.
- (censored) for years has been
asking me if I can do something
like this but I was
in the no business.
(group laughter)
- Bye guys.
Have a great night.
Such a pleasure.
Take care. See you later.
Bye guys.
Bye, great to see you.
Have a great night.
Make sure if
anybody ever feels like,
it's very possible that you
could have 39 things and you can
have seven in six months.
We need to smart
of how you, yeah.
You're good.
- [Rav] Thank you.
- You enjoyed it?
- [Rav] Yeah, yeah.
- [Woman 3] What
does winning mean?
I know you've kind of...
- [Gary] For me, it's
just about the journey
of building businesses.
It is my drug.
It is my oxygen.
I love it.
I love that.
I love this journey because
I want to see how we stack up
with me involved against the
other people that are trying to
capture the attention and so in
essence what it is is one big
game of how do
I provide the most value.
So in return, I get
the attention that I seek.
Like how do
I build the best building.
The best company for the people
in it and for the people that
are consuming it which
then creates a byproduct of it
becoming the standard
and, even more interesting,
how do I change businesses?
I love resetting
the rules of industries.
It was so fun for me to change
the wine business which was a
business that on
the lower price point,
there were low margins
but on premium wine over $30,
there was all the margin.
I came in and broke that and
I love the legacy of
changing an industry.
I love that.
So for me, winning
comes in two forms.
Just building very,
very, very large businesses.
I call it Honey Empires. Right?
How do I build a Honey Empire?
How do I build unbelievably
successful massive businesses in
a honey way, the right way,
that's good for
everybody involved.
Internally first and externally
second and then if I can leave a
legacy that we changed it.
Like if my Wikipedia says,
"Oh, and then he went into this
"business and now
everybody does it this way,"
that's super interesting to me.
Like breaking shit and
reinventing it has legacy.
I like the legacy of it.
("Small Conversations At
Parties" by Derek Pope)